police do have a lot of information this
morning more to come for sure
Steven paddock lived in a retirement
community in Mesquite Nevada now that's
about an hour and a half north east of
Las Vegas
Karen Castro of our affiliate that's
klas is in paddocks neighborhood with
mesquite police spokesperson his name is
Quinn Averett good morning to you both
good morning to you now we are learning
a little bit more information about the
suspect as investigators continue
combing through his home here in
Mesquite Nevada here with me this
morning is officer Quinn Everett with a
mesquite police department so first of
all just tell us when we're police able
to make entry into his home and what did
they find
so they the search warrant which we
helped Metro with we executed maybe
about two hours ago and as far as what's
found in there we're not releasing that
the detectives and the forensics are
still going through the home and they're
gonna be processing that which is going
to take quite a long time they want to
be very thorough any information or any
any evidence or anything that comes from
that home that's related to this
incident
we will be getting released through the
Las Vegas Metro Police Department but at
this point can residents in this
community at least rest easy that there
are not an immediate danger yes
everybody in this community should know
they're safe there's no immediate danger
there's no active threats that this was
basically a lone wolf or one-person
operation and we don't have any evidence
there's any any other concerns in the
community and what do we know about the
suspect do we know how long he's lived
here or do we know if he has some
run-ins with law enforcement here so
what's unique with the situation is that
we don't have any previous contacts with
this with this man we don't have any any
any contacts any law enforcement whether
it be just an arrest or a simple traffic
stop we haven't had any contact with him
whatsoever this area where he lives it's
a newer a part of the community these
homes aren't too old maybe a year at the
most
so we don't believe these lived here
much more than that just for those
watching right now that don't know the
layout of this community you said
there's only one way in one way out
which is why when officers serve that
warrant you guys had to tell some folks
to live leave the community there's lots
there's more than one way in and out but
the area he lives in is
certain part of the community where you
enter in and then the he lives at the
end of that community in a khole de sac
so yes for the safety of the those
concerned in the area the neighbors we
did ask them to leave their homes when
we executed the warrant just because we
weren't sure what we were dealing with
or what we might find and I'm pretty
sure this is not something that mesquite
sees every day correct yeah this is
especially this community up here it's a
very quiet community a very low crime
rate very clean we pride ourselves on
this key that we have a low crime rate
so this isn't something that we see a
lot have we heard from any residents who
live here who might know who this man is
any encounters they might have had with
him that's something we're actively
working this is early and investigation
obviously we're assisting Metro wherever
we can and as far as friends neighbors
acquaintances that's something that's
where she's looking into every thank you
very much with mesquite Police
Department and again they'd have no
known criminal history with the suspect
he presumably has been living here for
no more than a year given how new this
community here in Mesquite Nevada is for
now we'll send it back to you